hey everyone this is Steve valantro with
collider and I am here at our studio at
the cinema center at marble with Richard
linklater for Hitman how you doing sir
doing well man good to see you uh so I I
guess I have to start with the first
thing which is what is it like because
you've made a number of movies some get
better reviews than others what is it
like for this one where there's just
Universal acclaim
well in the big scope of things it's
it's better to be loved than not loved
but uh probably it's more gratifying in
the moment but long term who knows but
you know in the moment it's always yeah
it is actually you're one of these
people though that has done so many
movies over so many years and some are
now considered Classics like for example
Dazed and Confused one of my all-time
favorite films thanks and you know it's
been 30 years now but it's one of those
films that's really stood the test of
time did you know when did you realize
oh wait a minute this is really
resonating with people and might be
something special well I the first time
audiences were seeing it but I can't you
don't really know about a year later it
was still playing back then they still
have midnight screenings remember and uh
it played a full year at certain
theaters you know a little bit of the
theatrical run for however many weeks
and then it kicked to midnight and it
played for a year as a midnighter and
you know they're talking about yeah
people come in and you can smell the
reefer smoke in the theater it's like a
party film I was like that's interesting
you know so I don't know it it you hear
things but
you've moved on to your next film by
then so it's you know whatever well one
of the things we've talked about this uh
I think for Apollo 10 and a half but one
of the things that you are a master of
one of the many things is that you have
this insane ability to remember things
and apply those memories into your work
and it's and for people that don't
realize can you talk a little bit about
that because with dazed with so many of
your your films it's like you've been
transported back in time to that exact
moment and little random things that
most people don't remember are included
well
yeah I guess everyone's mind works
differently I guess I I always had this
kind of recall memory of little details
it's what to do with those those
exacting memories that clutter up your
Consciousness you know so I think a lot
of novelists have that or they're
describing the day in every detail some
people you kind of have that recall so
I think I have that all right I just use
it in in certain ways not on every film
but you know certain films that are kind
of that in that vein of personal and
autobiographical and oftentimes I really
have tried to say okay I'm recreating a
moment in time or a place in time and
that's it's always something
um fun to
to strive for but you know I'm doing
that sometimes not on a physical level
like maybe not the time period anything
but on a psychological level like
something that happened to me
transported to another place in time so
it's always personal you know so um
before we jump into Hitman which I have
so many questions about when you see
someone like me wearing this t-shirt
which is a complete bootleg do you get
upset are you like oh that's actually
pretty cool
I have to go that's that's actually
pretty cool yeah I mean I make t-shirts
or I used to make a lot of them and I
was like oh that's cool someone you know
it's easier now you just get a little
frame grab and do a thing but
um oh that's cool of course it is you
know we it's been a long time since I
was in Vienna shooting that movie
yeah coming up on 30 years 100 yeah does
it get do you enjoy when people ask you
will there be more or do you sort of
like like I'd rather you know what I
mean yeah you know that question begs
itself when you do a series you know
it's it's of course you know we never
got asked that after the first film
no one ever asked are you going to do
another knowing but after we did two
then that question then do three yeah
that question
but we we totally missed our nine-year
window so I don't know you know no plans
currently but hopefully it's a long live
yeah um I I could ask a million
questions but let's jump into why I get
to talk to you so hitman's fantastic oh
thank you um and so there's so much to
talk about but let's let's get into the
fact that you worked with Glenn when he
was like 14 or something 15. he was in
high school yeah and then it's like you
never know what's gonna happen and then
all of a sudden you know Glenn anyway
talk a little bit about how you made
this with Glenn and uh the origins of
the story you know kind of the most I
think anyone will tell you the most
rewarding kind of special thing about
doing what we do and being able to do
this over years is the long-term
relationships to just see people grow up
and see people change and you know
people you work with or know and it's
been fun to see Glenn you know he's
significantly younger than me but I
worked with him when he was a teenager
on Fast Food Nation just a small part
you know but I cast him amongst a lot of
teenagers like that guy's interesting
but he's 16 or whatever
and then uh
what felt like not many years later for
me but for him or a lot of years later
you know let's say 16 to 23 or four or
whatever five
um he he comes in on everybody wants
some and I was like oh wow that guy
he he grew up he became Glenn Powell on
the Glenn Powell we know today developed
in there and sure enough it's it wasn't
like he had some yellow brick road he
was like he really worked hard he
struggled in La he did all the things
you have to do to persist in an acting
career
and he he did all that and uh he would
he was just fully formed and we had so
much fun and everybody wants some and
then he came in and did a uh like a one
day Cameo for me on Apollo 10 and a half
and that was fun but you know over the
pandemic he called me up with this
um this article he had read and I was
like yeah I read that a long time ago I
do know that story from Texas monthly
and we just started collaborating on it
we started having you know Glenn's like
the greatest guy he's like
ideal collaborator like super smart
super funny all we do is laugh and make
each other's laugh and kind of keep
pushing each other too so I think this
thing reflects both of our greatest hits
maybe to kind of put our sensibilities
together and make this work and I like
collaborating with the actors too like
that's why I work with Ethan like he's a
future actor and I'm a future director
but at this moment we're just we're
screenwriters we're Conjuring this movie
together and I've done that with other
actors you know like I was saying Ethan
and Julie for instance and Glenn such a
such a great creative partner just
really fun was this a tough project
because I believe the film is for sale
here yeah we we did this on spec you
know we didn't we didn't have a
corporate parent we didn't you know no
one was financing us you know we we did
this pretty independently
so because it's kind of a strange film
on paper you know it's a hybrid what is
this could it be more in a like people
didn't totally get it so we did it we
just we we got it done old school and uh
yeah we're looking for a distributor so
I am very confident that this will be
sold
this is not I think yeah yeah it's just
you know hopefully to the right well but
it's a question of like um you know are
you guys looking for a big theatrical
push are you looking for just streaming
or you look depending those kind of
questions become where it could end up
yeah I don't know it's good to have
options and I don't know we'll just see
what comes at us I haven't really I
don't think I've been in this position
before or not in the modern sure era
where I've had to make certain decisions
so we're at a unique time I guess but
let's hope we have options that's what
you want in this world so yeah
whatever's best for the movie you know
like I said though I think it the fact
that it gets it got such good reviews
and everyone is so positive makes it you
know yeah it's I would like to anyway
moving past that so with with making an
indie like this did you guys what like
how long did you have to shoot it uh you
know I'm used to that not as long as you
would like you don't have the schedule
or the budget but you make it work you
know you just grind you you we we never
were not working on this
we'd work all weekend we'd finish
shooting in the day we'd work that night
on this you know it was there was so
many nuances we were trying to get
perfect and so what you don't have in
money and schedule you make up in prep
so long rehearsal long all that you plan
it out rehearse on location so you got
to show up and go you know some of these
scenes people are kind of so excited
about you know the scene where he goes
back and they have that kind of fake
fight or whatever
I mean we shot that and you know like
half a day and some films would take a
week maybe to shoot that or at least
several days we you know we just
but we were ready those actors were
ready that you know yeah also when you
know what you're looking for and what
you're gonna you know what you're gonna
do yeah you know I have it all planned
out to me the most relaxing place in the
world is on my own movie Set you know
some people think oh that's crazy like
isn't it volatile it's like no because
it's all planned I'm just having fun
doing what we've you know it's like all
the prep has been done we're just
experiencing it now it's like you know a
player you like the game because you've
worked really hard in the off season and
you know what I mean 100 game is where
it happens so I can feel like the set
I'm not creating it there I'm
experiencing it there so uh Glenn has a
lot of outfit changes he also has
sometimes tattoos oh yeah uh so talk a
little bit about what was your favorite
outfit if you will and did Glenn have a
different favorite oh my God this movie
was it was so fun to make because you
know we had worked on these looks and
you know I'd seen tests and we had all
these pictures and Glenn really went to
town on the different characters and we
we would talk about each one we dropped
a few and you know the series of
would-be Hit Men
and but the presentation was kind of the
same like we would be preparing the set
but Glenn has to go to makeup so he
would get out of the van or whatever
and be this guy and the whole crew
everybody's standing around we just go
but the best is the
the very odd
orange-haired guy with freckles and the
he was he's the last one we saved kind
of the best for last because he's just
so weird when he stepped that was the
last day of shooting too we kind of
snuck that one in when Glenn got out of
the van I'll never forget the whole crew
we just all went
who what the has happened what has
descended on her movies that who is this
creature from another planet it was so
funny it was just so funny so you know
that I like talking about the editing
process because it's where it all comes
together how did this how did this one
get shaped in ways you didn't expect
because it's also balancing like
different tones yeah this one was kind
of different from me if anyone wants to
like look too close it's a little more
plotty there's twists and turns and I
felt like I'm in a genre here I'm trying
to deliver in the film Noir genre in the
screwball comedy this is very plotty and
it turns and you know the audience has
to be we're manipulating the audience
they have to be oriented in a certain
way and we're you know so it's not my
usual flow but I mean that was the fun
Challenge and so I probably move things
around more in editing now than I would
on most movies usually the script and
our final shooting script is kind of the
movie it lays out largely like this this
we were able to move some things around
like put up front something that was
later and kind of shape something drop
some things all together yeah so it was
a little it was more shape Sandra and I
yeah it was a bigger post-production
even watching it with an audience and
kind of shaping it you know when you're
trying to make a crowd-pleasing
film that hits all these notes you want
to make sure it's Landing properly so it
was like okay well they want to know
more about Glenn you could sense what an
audience wanted oh they need a little
more they have questions at the end
we're going to answer those questions
you know I just I was kind of we were
crafting this thing to to to work in the
way we wanted it to so you know you just
gotta your collaborators become
you know everybody's watched it and what
people are thinking about it and what
you're intuiting
hearing what people are saying or how
they're reacting to it so but we were
always good it just you know brought it
to the Finish Line you know is there
anything that you cut out of this that
you had shot that you're like this just
doesn't work not really
not really I had kind of a montage in
their earlier kind of establishing the
tone the place of New Orleans and then
we thought well no one needs to you know
have to describe Nora everybody knows
New Orleans we don't have to we were
just kind of describing how it fits the
theme of the movie it's like we don't
have to do that like we don't need that
film doesn't need that let's just get
right into it so uh you're basing this
on a real person Gary Johnson yeah and
but you're also making a movie so talk a
little bit about balancing where you
felt like you could have fun and where
you wanted to actually like be real with
Gary yeah well the film's pretty
demarcated you know it's kind of like
everything up until the time where she
gets back in touch with him like he
meets her well I don't want to do
spoilers by the way so I want to avoid
certain things yeah yeah
I don't know if it's a spoiler but
there's a moment where the film we take
off once the couple kind of get going
that's where I think the genre really
kicks in of the kind of crime nor thing
and the screwball comedy centers around
that relationship
and a lot of that is kind of a flight of
fancy we took but Gary Johnson was a
real guy I knew him I
fascinating guy he did teach at a school
he taught psychology just a really
thoughtful guy we give him a little
shout out dedication at the end but uh
yeah he was this kind of introverted
interesting guy who took on these
disguises not to the extent we do in the
movie he said oh yeah we're trying to
make a movie and I was we were always
keeping it because we just saw it as
funny it was just a Darkly funny movie I
mean people who want to kill people that
doesn't sound very funny but since
they're not actually killing people it
seemed like if they were really killing
people that's not so funny to me but the
fact that they're bumbling toward it in
a kind of goofy uninformed way that I
thought well that's that's just funny I
just always saw it as Darkly comedic
so what's also interesting because I
think Gary was involved in like 70 or
yeah like a ton of things and so it just
it just makes you realize a lot of
people want people dead it's a
fascinating subject isn't it and the
fact that we live in a society where
people think you can
have someone killed I mean that's a myth
do you really think it's a myth though
it's absolutely a myth I mean I'm not
saying it doesn't happen but it happens
to you know the the lovers you know
the woman talks the young guy into
killing her husband you know like that's
a thing got it stuff like that happens
or a gang there are mob targeted
killings of course there's drug cartel
killings but there's those are I call
Affiliated killings you have a relation
with the Killer and the person doing it
they're either there's some relationship
there
um what the myth is is that there's this
retail I call it in the movie we sort of
deconstruct the Hitman movie in a short
amount it's pretty fun but I mean I've
been studying this for over 20 years
I've really kept my because when I read
the article and I talked to Skip I said
yeah I've kind of heard the Hitman he
goes yeah there's no record on public of
there ever being well it's so
fascinating so for 20 years I've been
really watching this and if you think
about it the the the movie they're
entrapping the person who wants a person
killed and it's it's fairly easy you
know you just someone shoots their mouth
off and they want someone killed thank
God
um homicide divisions are interested in
that and they set you you know you go
think you're talking to a hit man and
you know I had surveillance tapes of all
that uh you know all the research from
Gary it was fascinating to listen in on
these conversations so but now so like
they're buying just a retail product you
know it's that's what's so bizarrely
funny about it but if you think about it
you it would be so easy to flip that
you know the homicide division would say
okay I'm looking to kill someone I'm
just throwing it out there for Hitman oh
come in and let's talk let's negotiate
the hit here's the guy to kill and as
soon as you have the money you'd arrest
them it'd be so easy to get to catch
them think of it logically it'd be so
easy and have you ever heard in a news
thing well this guy was found shot in
the forehead today with a long powered
rifle we assume it's a hitman
you've never heard that you've never
heard a Hitman arrested and you've never
heard
they're so good at their jobs
um yeah so I don't know but I don't
expect this film to bust the myth I mean
we love it too much I was just at the
Venice football they're like three
Hitman movies there you know I'm like
I'm in a little category we're kind of
deconstructing the Hitman myth but we're
all pretty bought into it it's it's you
know I think films invented the Hitman
it's just such it's a great character
it's a great idea but the the
interesting area for me has developed
over the years like well why are we
invested in the Hitman is it because we
like the idea that you know someone
screwed me over I don't want to kill
anyone I'm a pacifist but you know you
screw me over enough I might just
reach into my savings account and have
you killed you're only alive because
I'm deciding not to do that you know is
it an empowering thing I don't know I'm
just spitballing why are we invested in
this notion I mean the idea it's kind of
like
snuff films or something you hear oh
those don't really those are fake anyway
they never really existed it's like
really but it's just a compelling thing
we kind of like people we like fun crazy
ideas but like like most conspiracy
theories there's just no basis to them
but we like it they're imaginative are
you telling me that Elvis is not still
alive
he lived a long time but then he died of
natural causes because he's an old guy
and he was a little overweight you know
he didn't have the best diet so he died
it's pretty well established he died in
the early 2000s right of course yeah
absolutely the last 20 years just he was
just a little quiet
you know no but it is like for me at
least like I love watching uh films that
took place in like apocalyptic futures
or like radically different things just
to imagine what that might be like
there's we're all imaginative said we
like this this realm of what if and all
that so I don't know we like and we like
something that includes us that's why
conspiracies Thrive you know they
include you you know it's just such a
bummer to get Knowledge from other
people that you have to deal with it's
just like it's like ah don't tell me
that and I don't want to believe that
global warming
just let me let me tell you what I think
I want to switch and and when you went
to Venice with the film and hear a tiff
uh what is it like watching the film
with an audience and are they laughing
at places that you did not expect do you
know what I mean yeah yeah well you
never know when you make a comedy like
you hope it permeates you hope they get
all your jugs and it's really satisfying
when you hear those Chuckles and you
hear the big laughs it's like okay wow
they're totally they're taking the ride
with us so that's that's fun I want to
make sure I pronounce your name right
Adria Audrey Audrey yeah just no no you
Audria A.D Audrey Audria
are uh fantastic together their
chemistry is like crackling so when did
you realize that they were so good
together and you know did you guys do
um uh like uh uh auditions together
chemistry read yeah all I needed I had
met Audria and I um just on Zoom you
know we had we had talked I was like oh
my God I called up Glenn and said I
think that this is Madison she's so
vivacious so funny and smart and sexy
you know like I think this is
I mean I want you to meet her and they
live kind of not far from each other
turns out and so they they had they were
gonna have like say they were gonna meet
at three o'clock
and then it was like 4 30 and I hadn't
heard back I thought I'd hear from Glenn
and then it's like 6 30 at night I said
oh man do I and then finally about 8 30
at night I got a call from Glenn saying
we were together five hours we were just
coffee became drinks and we were just
and I was like okay we got a movie
because I mean I knew that I just had to
hear it from them sure that they they
sort of clicked and knew what we were
trying to do with this movie and decided
to but the thing about it is you can
meet and have drinks and get along great
but it doesn't mean on camera no there's
gonna be that magic oh I knew I can put
two things together
knowing Glenn and then getting to know
her I was like okay this will this is
gonna work and then but just when you
start rehearsing you always have the
front row seat and we work on scenes I'm
like oh I can't wait I mean it's a year
plus away but I can't wait for this to
be in a movie uh so I like talking um
one of the things I've spoken to Roger
deacons a lot and he just shoots with
one camera and then you have Ridley
Scott who will shoot with like six
cameras or eight cameras and I'm curious
through your career how do you typically
like to shoot a scene and does it has it
changed as you've progressed not that
much I think we're all kind of stuck
with our own methodologies I like a
second camera especially on a
in the lower budget you can if you're
lit correctly you know you can get a
close-up and another angle sometimes at
the same time so I like two cameras when
possible
but yeah
I think if you're doing a big action I
mean Kurosawa would use you know one
take but you know 15 cameras of a raid
or something there's a there's a time to
have multiple cameras but I'm usually
not making a movie like that so
I'm a one or one to two camera
um it's so interesting to me because
there is no right way to make a movie no
and you know you look at like Fincher
and he's told me how he'll like shoot
something 35 times whatever their
number is and they'll use part
of take two part of take 17 part of take
31 to craft someone's performance but
then there's other people One camera and
that's the whole thing yeah well there's
as many ways you make a movie as there
are personalities and neurodivergencies
of directors right
when you think about your resume in all
the films you've made which ones do you
think changed the most in the editing
room in ways you didn't expect
the I think the most malleable films in
post that I kind of feel like were
crafted I mean hitman's in the top 10
percent of that just because it it got a
little we could shape shift it a little
bit but uh probably Waking Life
that was
that was never linear still isn't in my
mind I could I was moving stuff around
kind of with a flow that was fun Sandra
would scream at me like we never argue
but she's like no I said well what if
the whole thing you know she's so that's
the only time because it was pretty wide
open so anyway it was such a Trippy film
but that's about it I don't I don't
think you know it's always a craft you
know you're always crafting
everything you know to me it's a put
down the actors say oh I had to craft
their performance in post but I learned
with I mean I've I've been doing it long
enough I went from analog to digital in
the editing and it was sure nice if
you're not
in the middle of a big camera move and
you're cutting like oh my God once you
got digital you could use I could use
that little bit from take seven I could
use that little bit that line is best
where before when you had to kind of
take the whole real
rewind it put it up on the stand get a
new one out get to that it was like you
know what take three is really the best
overall but you know that line on take
seven is better you know you did it you
did it but it's just natural human labor
laziness you probably defaulted a little
more into that so it was I found it very
refreshing in those situations to have
all that material quickly available that
you could like digital editing was the
way your mind worked it was great I had
never been so thankful for a jerk you
know post-production got digital really
fast it's literally what I just said
about Fincher yeah like I mean you
couldn't do that with you know back when
you're in or you could you just took
three years to edit your movie you know
like Kubrick would spend years editing
because he thought that way and it was
yeah you would
it just was very very time consuming I
also think that a lot of people don't
realize how instrumental George Lucas
was into digital editing because he was
thinking about that with um you know he
really helped that too it was like Hey
the video was always a tool to help you
yeah to yeah digital video editing yeah
even before it was digital it was video
because you could edit video quickly
like news footage type approach I'm also
curious uh what like with this film what
cameras did you use and have you been
using the same cameras on all your
recent films no it changes around a lot
you know the Alexa the different Alexa's
so I don't really obsess about that too
much
so you know whatever the latest one that
kind of work you know some people
stick with a camera it's like it changes
so much I think the big leap was just to
start shooting digital anyway I was kind
of later to that than most I think
um so I work with dick Pope who's
Deacon's partner and we did he hadn't
shot digitally and I hadn't either it
was Bernie 10 years ago dick was like we
were like the Alexa camera
he did some tests I think with deacons
and said you know this is starting to
look pretty good I think I could finally
do it but that was people been shooting
digital 10 years and I just didn't like
the way it looked especially night
exteriors I think that looks like crap
I'm not doing that
and so finally it was like you know
that's got the latitude it's got the
look yeah let's try it but even since
then I've shot on film it really depends
on the movie to me the choices film or
digital but within the digital
I mean I've been pretty much Alexa but
you know it's not exclusive I agree with
you though the early days of digital it
looked like and recently now the
cameras are incredible yeah no I'm just
like whatever latest greatest camera
that gets you the look of your movie I
wouldn't get too precious about it you
know I I completely agree also some
people have talked to me about like the
lenses they use you know they'll take a
newer camera but use like 60s lenses
yeah you know you got that option yeah
um so talk a little bit about what it's
like in Texas now in the film Community
if you don't mind because Austin is
obviously just a great town uh outside
of the rest of Texas
um sorry did I say that out loud uh no
but I'm just that used to be a joke the
only thing wrong with Austin is
surrounded by Texas but I don't believe
that anymore if you really look at
politically if we're talking all those
cities all the big cities are are blue
cities it's just still a red State
barely I don't want to open that door
yeah I mean Texas is trying
yeah I wanted to try harder we did too
um but you know we're there front line
you know staying there trying to make it
uh make it better we're impeaching our
attorney general as we speak which I by
the way maybe I never thought that was
ever going to happen neither it's an
encouraging sign that well he really you
mean I mean how bad do you have to be
like is there a line anywhere in the
world
um I used to listen I'm gonna stop there
and I'm just gonna say I really mean it
when I say congrats on Hitman no thank
you and um I really encourage everyone
out there when it eventually comes out
to seek the film out and um I really
thank you for coming in today it's
always a pleasure oh always always great
talking to you with you thanks for this
checking out the movie oh for sure
thoughts so